- The idea of looking
at the story of Ireland,
and Irish America on film,
is something that had
always fascinated me,
because I had grown up in a country,
where the depiction of
ourselves in cinema was so rare,
that I remember once being at a film,
which was preceded by a short
documentary about Dublin.
And it was so rare for Dublin
to see itself on the screen,
that when it came on in
this short documentary,
it got a round of applause.
What I really wanted to do, I think,
was to examine something at a filmic level
that had occupied me, which is,
who are we and how are we perceived
by audiences outside Ireland?
It occurred to me that a great deal
of what we think and know and perceive
about each other is
through the world of film.
We need to hear the
authentic, indigenous voices
of other people through film.
The problem with not having
an indigenous film industry,
is that other people come in
and make your films for you.
Your point of view, your
perspective of the world
is told through somebody else's focus.
The most well-known film
that was made in Ireland
was "The Quiet Man".
It was a film that mythically invented
the kind of Ireland, that,
not just Irish people wanted to see,
but that seemingly
everybody around the world
wanted to see.
I think it was in about in 1982,
Neil Jordan made "Angel",
which was the first film
by a young, Irish filmmaker
to deal with, as they call them,
the troubles in the north of Ireland.
It was a very tumultuous time
in Irish and British politics.
But out of that came Jordan and Sheridan,
and this was the first
time that Irish filmmakers
had access to the means of
telling their own story.
It kind of interests me when people say,
"Oh, Ireland. Yeah,
Ireland, they've always
"had their troubles with
politics over there."
But, the Irish peace process,
which was many years in the making,
was signed ten years ago.
And it's an inspiration to the world,
that after 400 years of warfare,
a peace accord was signed.
The other film that I chose,
"The Wind That Shakes the Barley",
is the first film that
I could look at and say,
"If I knew nothing about
the history of Ireland,
"that's the film that would
tell me the story of it."
It also has huge parallels with
the war in Afghanistan and Iraq,
although it's set in Ireland in 1920.
The idea of invasion and terrorism,
and I hope that the themes
will be as compelling
to American audiences as they will be to
people from other places.
There's a kind of an audience, I think,
that wants to see just a certain
kind of film from Ireland.
And young, Irish filmmakers,
their problem is that, off their back,
they have to get the label of being Irish.
Just like Roddy Doyle
said about being a writer,
he said, "Every Irish writer
has to get Joyce off his back
"before he can become the
writer he's meant to be."
The future of Irish film depends on
young filmmakers like that,
that they can tell their own stories,
and that they can be universal.
I think these are not just Irish films,
they're also American films,
in the sense that we're all connected
by the same concerns through the ages.
Not just 1950 or 1850,
but way before that.
Although technology has advanced hugely,
the human condition,
it's debatable whether
that has changed, and that's
why people make films.
They make them about the human condition.